>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Patricia Baine: Good afternoon.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Patricia Baine:
Welcome to Compositions
with African Poets and Writers.
We're glad to see you all.
We -- today, in addition
to our featured speaker,
we have his Excellency,
Ambassador Malanga [phonetic]
from the Republic of South Africa.
Let's give all of us a
round of applause please.
[ Applause ]
Showcasing African writers
whose work has contributed
to increasing the knowledge
about the continent of Africa
and her people is the
objective of this series;
Conversations with
African Poets and Writers.
It's a partnership of the
African Poets and Writers Division
of the Library of Congress, the
African and Middle Eastern Division,
the Howard University, and the
African Society -- four partners.
This unique opportunity that you
will experience offers you the
ability to peer into the
richness and diversity
and creativity of African writers.
You -- it will allow you to sort of
peer into African life and culture.
Now, all our past programs
can be found on the Library
of Congress website
for your viewing.
You're going to have a
fantastic program today.
Enjoy the program.
We're headed to South Africa,
a fabulous, rich country.
So please silence your
cell phones, as usual --
you know the housekeeping items --
and engage your imagination,
and enjoy yourselves.
And now I will invite Rob Casper,
who is the head of the Poetry
and Literature Center at
the Library of Congress.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Casper: Thank
you Patricia.
It's been a joy to work with you
and to have you lead the summit
as we continue this series,
Conversations with
African Poets and Writers.
This is the beginning of our
sixth year of the series.
It's been a wonderful
partnership with the summit
and with the African Middle
East Division and the Poetry
and Literature Center at
the Library of Congress.
I'll tell you a few things about
the Poetry and Literature Center;
we are the home to
the US Poet Laureate.
Our current Poet Laureate, the
twenty second, is Tracy K Smith.
We host programs like this all
throughout the year with a number
of divisions at the library.
We're most delighted to partner with
the next person who will get up here
and tell you a little bit about
the event and the whole division
with this series, but if
you want to find out more
about our programs you can
visit www.llc.gov/poetry.
This program and this series
wouldn't exist without the great,
wonderful support of Mary-Jane
Deeb, the chief of this division.
It's so inspiring to be here
among all these books and to think
of the great authors we've had come
through here and connect to us,
champion the range of writing --
diasporic and writing
from the continent --
that we want to support and want to
sort of get greater knowledge of.
Big thanks to Mary-Jane
Deeb for doing that.
And she'll come up here and
welcome our next introducer.
Mary-Jane.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Thank you.
Thank you Rob and thank
you Patricia.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, Chief of the
African Middle East Division,
which is responsible for
recommending, reserving,
serving the connections
of 78 countries --
including the entire continent
of Africa, the Middle East,
Central Asia, the Caucuses --
and for organizing programs --
such as the one today -- that
highlight the contributions
of writers from the countries
and regions we represent.
Our partners have been
absolutely fantastic.
The person you just heard
before, Robert Casper --
the head of the Poetry Center --
has been with us from the very
beginning in funding the series.
Patricia Baine, President
of the Africa Society,
has been with us the whole
way from the very beginning.
And Professor Mbye
Cham is our newer --
newest partner from the
University of Howard.
Our series has become well-known
and well-established and has brought
to the library, and to our patrons
and readers as well to all those
who access the library's
webcast around the world,
some of the best writers
from Africa.
From those who are no longer
with us, like Chinua Achebe
and Ali Mazrui -- the Albert
Schweitzer Professor of Humanities
at Binghamton University -- to Poet
Laureates like poet Kigo Sitsin --
[phonetic] the Poet Laureate to
the new generation of writers
like Emma Dukone --
[phonetic] from the Codebuer --
[phonetic] Nigerian writer Igoni
Barrett, the poet of the Congo,
de Banga, from the Democratic
Republic of the Congo, Tisian Salat,
[phonetic] the Gambian poet,
and so many -- so many -- more.
And today we have with us a
great poet, a great writer,
from South Africa, -- Antjie Krog.
And she will be introduced by our
partner in arms and the supporter
and co-sponsor of this series,
Professor Mbye Cham
of Howard University.
Mbye Cham.
[ Applause ]
>> Mbye Cham: Thank you Mary-Jane.
Good afternoon.
It's a distinct pleasure
to be a partner
in this very important series.
My name is Mbye Cham.
I'm a faculty member at Howard
University in the Department
of African Studies and
I'm also the Director
of the Title Six National Resource
Center for African Studies,
which is one of 10 Africa
area studies -- Title Six --
funded by the Department
of Education --
US Department of Education.
It's my distinct honor to
introduce Miss Antjie Krog.
And it is where Antjie
Krog's iconic status,
as well as South Africa's most
popular critically acclaimed
and politically courageous
poets, began when she was 18
with her first collection entitled,
"Daughter of Jephta," 1970.
Within the next two years she
published a second collection
entitled, " Januarie-Suite."
Since then she has published
more than 10 volumes of poetry,
much of which has dealt with
love, apatite, the role of women,
and politics of gender and has been
translated into several languages,
including English and Dutch.
Krog started publishing prose in
the 1990s, developing a unique form
of autobiographical writing,
which combines factual
and fictional analytical elements.
The best known of these is her
account of reporting on the Truth
and Reconciliation
Commission, entitled,
"Country of My Skull," 1998.
Some of you may have
seen the film version
of that, with Samuel Jackson.
It was here first work to
be published in English
and brought her international
recognition.
She has also written a play and I'm
going to take a stab at this here
in Afrikaans; [foreign language].
How did I do?
[laughter] I'm sure she
will probably provide a
translation there.
And this play was performed
at the Arts Festival in
South Africa in 1999.
Antjie Krog has also been a
journalist and edited many years --
for many years -- the
independent African journal,
"Die Suid-Afrikaan," cofounded
with Hermann Giliomee in 1984.
She also joined the South African
Broadcasting Corporation, SABC.
And for two years contributed
to the radio program, "AM Live,"
which she reported on South Africa's
Truth and Reconciliation Commission.
She's also an academic,
having joined the Arts Faculty
at the University of
Western Cape in 2004.
Krog's many works,
both poetry and prose,
have received almost every award
available in her country for poetry,
translation, and non-fiction.
Among them, the esteemed
Hertzog Prize for "Lady Anne,"
1989 and for "Synapse," 2014.
The Oliver Shreiner prize for,
"Country of My Skull," 1998.
And the Vita Poetry Award for,
"Down to My Last Skin," in 2000.
Internationally she has also
been awarded this second award
from the Hiroshima Foundation
for Peace and Culture as well
as the Open Society Prize from
the Central European University,
previous winners of which were
Yogen Harbormast [phonetic]
and Vaklav Havelo.
[phonetic] Since 2004 Antjie Krog
has been an extraordinary professor
of literature and philosophy at
the University of the Western Cape.
Bucknell University Press
is proud to be the publisher
of the first English
translation of Antjie Krog's
"Lady Anne: A Chronical in Verse."
It's a distinct pleasure
to welcome her to here,
Library of Congress,
and to this series.
Thank you.
Welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Antjie Krog: Pero,
[assumed spelling] I feel I lie
because I blatantly indulge
in words and uses Eros.
In the face of so much
injustice if poetry perseveres
as luxury it also becomes a lie.
I live on the other side of
injustice, therefore I have the time
to tune chords precisely
around the private gland.
And why not?
This country has already
been ruined.
Then the order comes.
"Words should be AK47s,
should always fight.
Poetry should be useable, DEET,
relate the struggle, take sides.
Weeds are mightier than roses."
Tortured poetry grows
wild in phonetic rain.
How can I safeguard this poem
against the stupidity of politics?
Distressed I stand,
looked upon with suspicion,
my most ordinary words refused.
But I'm ashamed by the
poet's unheard of poetry,
which screams on the
other side of all breath.
There, will your eyes stop
now gravel road spasa?
[phonetic] Someone may have
disappeared before dawn.
The wind moves as if in war.
Children kick a ball in the
townships where three quarters
of the world lives and waits,
rightly so, for equality.
Shy like you, brave or
stupid, or perhaps all
of really lazy and corrupt like us.
From the hands hangs
this treacherous carpet
of hope and hunger and dream.
But the poet stands aside.
He hears of the petitions;
Moses, motions of injustice.
He has stopped writing poems.
No poetry.
The thoughtful poet stands
smoke blue with cold.
Barely audible she
repeats her arrest.
Her sentences melt from her tongue.
Not in print.
Not in photographs.
Not in statistics.
Every fear it is damp.
Rumors of disappearances,
torture, and anonymous deaths.
The struggle filters through
with inaudible fierce noises,
into the shady suburbs and we
have become a country of rumors.
If my senses cannot wean the
cries from the leaves or the blood
from the barricades of
grossities or pick up murder
from the blockades near my desk I
will die hardened in the crossfire
of pencil and paper, which
always fight back to the truth.
All the writers are
dead aren't' they?
They can't write about
or of the oppressed.
And the oppressed writer
is drowning in anger.
This is what's being said.
Aesthetics is the only ethic.
They say as well, "But the demands
do not tolerate neutral ground."
Between evils I choose nothing.
I was born of a guilt
of greed and scorn
where I felt myself at times apart.
A hedge between myself and
them, myself and the slaughter,
nothing ever prepared me for hunger
and homelessness, lanklessness.
I tried to find a bridge,
but everything is burning
and I'm looking for a guide.
Beware of propaganda,
rhetoric, coarse change of words
under the whip of lies without
even the charm of consciousness.
Is aesthetics ever useful?
I never stopped studying survival.
With this fragile,
most light-hearted category I
diligently investigate every
relation to breathe.
Yes, to breathe.
The language has never been
useless or fake, but only --
although the poet may desire
indulgence and the procreation
of political words,
the injustice is real.
And whatever I write,
which will survive,
sprouts from this very futile
clash between luddite and lie.
So to find the bridge I
tried to find a metaphor
in terms of Lady Anne Lindsay.
In 1797 Lady Anne's husband, Andrew
Barnard, was sent to the Cape
of Good Hope as secretary
to Lord Macartney,
the first British Governor
of the Cape Colony.
Barnard was given this post
by the Secretary of War
in Colonies, Henry Dundas.
Lady Anne was well connected to
both Dundas and the Prince of Wales,
accompanied her husband and became
the First Lady of the Colony
in the absence of Lord
Macartney's wife.
Her letters and diaries are
filled with acute observations
and assessments of the situations
and people she came across in
and around the Cape
during her period
of residence from 1797 to 1802.
She also produced hundreds
of drawings and paintings,
of which most are in
Balcarres House,
her ancestral home in Scotland.
So the volume opens with her
on ship on her way to Cape town
and it's a letter to Henry Dundas.
Who is it that bloody-well
sends me downwards
to the south to foreign soils?
And above all, why?
Fabricated from an
abundance of stains
and knobs my highland
origin always matters to me.
Stony gators and mist,
an intimacy there
where water lists the
only reflection.
Like you sir, I was
purified for castles.
On deck, under my blanket,
my senses sting.
I am suspended grim swine in
the rigging of sound and salt.
My fingers fondle blocks of amber,
carmine and new cinnabar marked
down by Newman's in London to pound
this retched life of yours and mine
into dignity, into blains
of poetry and paint.
Suddenly, out of the sea,
slightly to one side,
a parasol of crystal
shimmering over skin of a whale.
My husband fires his gun, a jet
of bubbles vibrates
thunderously from a spout.
Will this whale surface sheariously
[phonetic] beneath the ship
so that we tumble, sucked into a
vortex with blank-eyed animals,
sails billowing under
water, wobbling deck,
cannon snouts pointing upwards
under fleeces of hair --
mine a blond, combless
fern of fin in a ring
of roses slowly sinking
to the dregs.
But of course I find her
quite useless as a guide.
I wanted to live a second life
through you, Lady Anne Barnard,
show it is possible to
hone truth with the pain,
to live an honorable life within
so much privilege, weave a language
of revolution and conspiracies,
liberate slaves,
clinically plunder royalty,
and with your expedition
through the interior, cleave
the Boors to the bone.
But from your letters you
immerge, hand on the hip,
talented but a frivolous fool.
Then in crafty ink, snob, naive
liberal, being swayed away
from your principles by your
useless husband's pampering.
You never had real pluck and now
that your whole puerile life has
arrived on my desk I go berserk.
As metaphor my lady, you
are not worth a fuck!
An inscription in her
journal, from --
she lived in the castle of the
Good Hope and when ships came
in they brought letters from
families and newspapers, etcetera
and you can send something
back to your families.
From the ship anchoring to the
side I hastily prepare parcels
and letters.
The coming and going of ships,
high ranking officers movements lie
like an umbilical cord
to the castle.
Sweeping my eye across Table Bay has
become second nature and the thrill
of locking my door and
slowly, mouthful by mouthful,
tasting the post, the latest
in newspapers, letters,
the written word the only
harbor of the travelling heart.
But then the smell hits us.
Unearthly, so putrid, it seems
the most primordial of stenches.
"It's coming from the
bay," says the cook.
But by midday everyone knows, a
slave ship is unlawfully looking
to put to land 609 Congolese.
My husband suspects
the hold is underwater.
A few have drowned.
Rice, nuts, manioc is finished and
the obviously greedy upstart captain
of the ship implies that
Governor Young planned it all,
while he apparently hissed, "Did
you have to hang this maggots nest
for all and sundry
at the Cape to see?"
But why does it smell so?
"Annie, in the ship," this
is my stalwart husband,
"they are lying row
upon row, packed,
shackled to form full three
strings, shelf upon shelf.
The doctor does not dare go down
because of diarrhea, heat, stench,
and the deck, slippery
from mucus and blood."
I turn the dessert spoon over and
over on the tablecloth, silver,
expensively heavy, and catch myself
for days staring from every window
at the doomed ship in the bay.
At dusk a lament drifts towards
the castle, a kind of howl,
subbing from that abdomen of
that pleading cargo of misery.
Through my telescope I see on the
deck shackled groups swaying to
and fro in a macabre
treaty against death.
A shoal of fins circling the
ship, waiting for the stiff tussle
of bodies cut loose every
morning and thrown overboard.
After I had seen that for many days
my brain rushed forth with a dim
and determined sense of
unknown modes of suffering.
In my thoughts was a darkness, call
it solitude, a blank desertion,
know familiar shapes of
trees, of sea or sky,
no colors of green fields, but huge
and mighty forms that do not live
like living men move slowly
through my mind by day
and were the trouble of my dreams.
Haunt me. Haunt me like a fever.
This poem's about the first state
of emergency in South Africa,
not the second state of
emergency in South Africa.
So the bard that writes about Lady
Anne has to account in her own way
for the things that are
happening in her own life.
And how do you write?
How do you hold yourself as a poet
and as a privileged white
person accountable in that time?
So Lady Anne then goes back
to the -- just a second.
Sorry, I'm just trying
to get the right poem.
She goes -- they go back to England
and then her husband gets a job
to come back to Cape Town.
She is very anxious because
they don't have money
that she can go back with him.
So he has to go alone.
But I want to conclude
the bard's story
with a poem about the soul fish.
And the soul fish is a -- in
Afrikaans we call it a tongue fish,
but the soul is born like this.
It moves down to the bottom
because it gets eaten.
So to escape being
eaten it moves down.
The one part becomes the other part.
The one eye moves from the
one side to the upper side.
The mouth changes.
The upper side then becomes darkened
and so that fish then survives
on the bottom because
it has adapted.
So I have written a poem about
my children and this image
of the soul fish which Lady Anne
for the first time describes
in one of her diaries.
The light over my desk
streams into darkness.
I await my visitors on paper.
My four children, finely
balanced between anal and dorsal,
tiny fins at the throat,
constantly stirring,
their eyes uncommonly soft.
In the shallow, brackish
water your mother treads,
playing with the metaphors.
Come here across dictionaries
and blank pages.
How I love this delicate little
school, these fish of mine
in their four strong
flotilla lured so close now.
What should I feed you?
Dear child of the lean
flank, yield to the seabed.
Yes, the stretching makes you
ache, but mother holds you to her.
Mother is here.
The eye beneath, like father's
wondrous blue, migrates cautiously
with a complex bunching
of nerve and muscle
until it's up beside the other.
Pert little mouth, almost
pulled out of shape,
with time the tongue will
settle in its groove.
Pigment of the upper
flank begin to darken.
And up to the surf between sand and
stone you lie, meshed with bedrock
and never again to
pray or take flight.
I press my mouth against
each distended face.
Mother knows you will
survive the tide.
Lady Anne lets her husband then go
alone and she worries about him.
She writes a letter from London.
Where will this letter
find you, best beloved?
If I could choose again I would not
have you return you to the Cape.
May fair winds attend you
and blow you back soon.
I travel everywhere with a
small picture of your face.
At times your eyes look saddened.
And I think about you in the warm
Cape and memories of that mountain,
that seven foot percolate up,
and how I took all the
wrong tubes of watercolor.
Oh, how I -- misjudged that
brutal and blissful light.
Look after yourself.
I miss you.
My days are ailing without you.
He writes back.
I shudder when I think what
space there is between us.
Pray for me sometimes dearest love.
I never fail to do so for you.
Andrew Barnard.
And then of course he dies
there and she gets the message.
The six walnut trees in pots and my
hands dirty when the message came.
But how could it be?
I had a letter yesterday.
How can it be?
How can it be that that day passed
over me as if it was any other day
that I sleep, have tea, laugh,
add water while half
of me is already dead.
The slave brought me a handful
of relics that they found
with your body; a locket
with my hair,
the green purse I knitted
for you, your medicine.
You died of fever says the
slave, near Sternenbosh.
[phonetic] The doctor from
the Cape was too late.
There was no one with you.
You were buried on the
road to Green Point,
a small funeral and
wind from the sea.
Tonight everything speaks
through the dead towards me.
Your brittle bundle of bones, my
longest loved beloved lies lonely
and longingly cradled
somewhere lost and [inaudible].
I'm overwhelming awake tonight.
Of me so little has become.
You are all I had in this
world, beloved deathling.
Alone and cold it is behind my ribs.
Africa had me giving up all.
It is so dark.
It is so bleak.
Soft beloved torture, of
me so little has become.
I'm down to my last skin.
[ Applause ]
>> Laverne Page: My
name is Laverne Page.
I'm an area specialist here in the
African Middle Eastern Division.
And I work with the Southern
African countries and it's my honor
to be here today to converse with --
I've been practicing
[foreign language].
[laughing] I studied Afrikaans for
a while years and years ago, oh yes.
So for those of you who don't know
much about the library I would just
like to tell you that we have a
vast collection of research material
about and from the
African Continent.
And within that there's an amazing
amount from and about South Africa
in all formats -- so newspapers,
government publications, films --
all topics -- education development,
literature, poetry, drama --
and in the nine official
languages of South Africa --
such as Afrikaans, so the
first language of our speaker.
We have quite a bit of her
work in our collections.
If you search our online
catalogue by keyword there are
at least 54 hits of -- for
monograph records -- about her.
So to start off our question
and answer period I'll only ask
for questions because I
know that you have questions
and I want to offer you my time.
So I'll ask four questions --
two we always ask and then the other
two I'll start off asking about
"Lady Anne," which was
first published in 1989
and was recently republished
by Bucknell University Press,
the first time a complete volume of
poetry of yours has been translated
from Afrikaans into English.
So I'm wondering if you could
tell us how you used Lady Anne
as a metaphor to talk about
social issues of the 1980s
and how do you the present English
poems speak to continuing issues
of power, class, privilege,
and racial injustice
that disfigure our world?
--
>> Antjie Krog: Thank you for such
an honor [inaudible] African writers
that [inaudible].
Lady -- at the end of the 80s --
that was before the [inaudible]
of Nelson Mandela [inaudible].
The issue was the discrepancy,
the difference, between white
and black, rich and poor.
And it was the whites were
[inaudible] the black or whatever.
So the volume is obsessed
with; how do you deal
with the whites standing
of privilege?
So I'm trying to use her I think
to deal with that and I abused her.
There are -- I appropriate
her, which if she was black
or if she was not white and
royalty would have been a problem,
but since the British kills her
maybe [inaudible] I can't feel
too bad.
[inaudible] Yes, that
is how I [inaudible].
Then Nelson Mandela happened and
I was a bit ashamed of this poem
because it was talking
about these top issues
and here was this unbelievably
wonderful, forgiving period.
And -- but when I retranslate --
when I translated them now yeah,
I realize; no, it was just a poem.
It was a wonderful poem.
[inaudible] that we
are still at that point
and that issue will
now be fought out.
>> Laverne Page: Okay, thank you.
I'd like to ask you
something about language,
which is a very sensitive
issue everywhere.
I was told that you are
passionately committed
to the indigenous languages.
So I'm wondering what that means.
South Africa has nine official
languages and most, it appears to me
in written form, are not thriving.
So are they endangered?
At one point our division had to be
quite selective in what we acquired
in Afrikaans because
there was really
so much material that was coming.
Now it's less and less.
And I'm wondering if it
appears that way to you too,
that there's less Afrikaans
literature that's being produced?
So my question is; is
Afrikaans endangered?
>> Antjie Krog: Afrikaans
literature?
Is it endangered?
Okay, maybe just divert
to the [inaudible] poem [inaudible]
then I'll come to the second poem.
[laughing] The University of Western
[inaudible] seeing a large project
that's received by the National
Institute of Humanities Research.
To translate classical text from
indigenous languages into English
and the classical text has
been identified by scholars
in those areas of languages.
And so two novels from closer
variety [inaudible] famous
[inaudible] constantly are
quoted from, but 90 percent
of the people -- you know
even people who speak situtu,
[phonetic] are -- don't
necessarily [inaudible].
So those two novels
are being translated.
There's two novels in Zulu, also
a classical one by [inaudible]
and then another one that is
more current, about the fight
between the [inaudible],
they are wonderful,
wonderful thriller of
a novel [inaudible].
And another novel in Situtu -- a
play in Situtu and then an anthology
of poems from those languages.
And what all those texts have
in common is wideness either
in the back of it or
it's encroaching
or it is already eroding.
So it's -- African intellectuals
who are educated, could write well,
were read and they were
responding, I want to say,
to the black era of that language.
You see it was a strange time in
South Africa where you could feel
that people were writing
for the white era.
Mainly explanations and
mainly -- and this is --
it's absolutely fantastic
text and I'm not sure
if it's this what they [inaudible]
[laughter] Afrikaans is --
was for many years already
in language with English.
It had a [inaudible]
who supports English.
You know English is
supported by the world.
So you don't -- a government
need not support English.
So the apatite [inaudible]
supported Afrikaans,
dictionaries were excellent.
You know we had our own
newspapers, we have two
or three publishing houses.
We have our own universities,
etcetera.
Now that has changed after
1994 because the table now has
to be shared with the
non-indigenous languages
and that has had several
consequences.
Well, maybe we publish less, but
I think art that is being written
in Afrikaans is very,
very interesting.
It's -- there are voices
-- because Afrikaans --
60 percent of Afrikaans
speakers are not white, hey?
It's -- in South Africa they
would be termed "colored."
Here we -- I'm not sure, but
-- so they speak Afrikaans,
they're not white,
and they are derived
from other areas --
from another background.
And [inaudible] coming from that.
>> Laverne Page: Okay.
Okay, thank you.
To get to the two questions that
relate to African literature
in general, I would like know
who your favorite new South
African poets and writers are.
And what do you think makes
their work distinctly African?
>> Antjie Krog: [inaudible] let
me just start with [inaudible].
There's a young poet takes us
between old [inaudible] poet.
[inaudible] She performed
[inaudible] But some effectively --
and such -- had built up such a
fan-base and she didn't even mind
that she was not published
or whatever.
And then one day someone had
heard her and contacted her
and said, "Anyone published you?"
"No." And so he has published her.
It's a small, tiny print and gave
money to publish [inaudible] poetry.
And before the book came out
there were already 2,000 orders.
>> Laverne Page: And that press is?
>> Antjie Krog: June.
[assumed spelling]
>> Laverne Page: That's okay.
>> Antjie Krog: That's okay.
Her name is Kolega Putuma.
[phonetic] And she is an oror
[phonetic] before who also writer --
of course [inaudible] She is
bringing a non-easy remembering
of the past.
So it's not always that the past was
perfect or the past was just bad.
That's a very complex situation.
Then we have wonderful writers.
And in our language and in English
our rappers and poets of the word
on one side, on the
other side are poets
of the page and poets of the stage.
It's a very big division.
But in Afrikaans we've managed
to keep everybody impressed.
And so there are some
wonderful rappers in Afrikaans.
It's a wonderful [inaudible].
He's a tall guy and he just -- it
just thumps out under [inaudible].
Yes. We have -- and yes.
[inaudible] a wonderful, young
black students who now are
at top universities are
writing their experience
of being trapped in
this also privilege.
And you know it.
And don't feel easy about it.
Feel in one way they earn it and in
another way they can't live with it.
>> Laverne Page: Oh, thank you.
Right. Okay, lastly; what
do you think is the future
for African literary writers?
Both diasporic and
from the continent?
And what steps need to be
taken to bring more recognition
from the international community?
>> Antjie Krog: I once
asked them [inaudible]
Who is English language spies?
Who goes out and says,
"This book needs
to be translated into English"?
And they looked at me and
said, "They will find us.
They will find us."
As if suggesting that good books
were being translated into English,
it's not necessary to go
out there and find them.
I think that's one of the
problems that people who buy books
or who advertise books or whatever,
they don't go out to
look what is available
in indigenous languages
as well as English.
And at least these texts
that are now being translated
that I think there are so many other
books from South Africa like Shocka,
[phonetic] or Thomas
Bufulmu [phonetic],
the lynch man from Peter Malensbook.
[phonetic] The two -- the only
two books that have been written
in an indigenous language
that have been classed
as the top 100 books written by
Africans in the twentieth century.
That is actually a fantastic list.
And one most successful books
have in common I think is
to -- is another anthology.
The world is bankrupt, hey?
And the whole issue of humanity
is bankrupt, mostly in the world.
And from that continent comes text
that provides an alternative
to that.
It's not necessarily respected
because in many ways the world
kneels down to individualism
to [inaudible] and to a
richness and all of that.
And here is another completely other
way of looking at life and at nature
and at the cosmos that I think --
People are starving for.
Laverne Page: Well --
[laughter] Thank you.
I've had my turn.
Now would you like
to ask a question?
Okay.
>> Yes, thank you very
much for your readings.
I'm curious about the
writings that is done
in Afrikaans by the author Kans.
[assumed spelling] Does
it reflect some kind
of [inaudible] Does it embrace
the presence or is it used
by the African artist as a
resistance to the present?
>> Antjie Krog: Oh, that's
such a good question.
And [inaudible] And [inaudible]
What I'd say now is for Afrikaans,
as well as for English, we
also [inaudible] So he writes
about [inaudible] So
most people write
about the parts they are
being resistant to the parts
because that's a part of
South Africa they think,
"Oh, I understand well."
So I -- everyone can be
-- everyone understands.
There's one Afrikaans writer
that writes about now.
He has [inaudible] and he does a
[inaudible] And he is [inaudible]
And he writes [inaudible]
I think he's [inaudible]
And that is the closest
you might come to one
of these [inaudible] There's no
other [inaudible] Sometimes people
will imagine a place where
[inaudible] doesn't work it just --
if you write [inaudible]
it's actually white people
but just black scenes, which then
creates another kind of a problem.
Or, what I found [inaudible] most
famous South African [inaudible] was
a futuristic hope taking
place in South Africa,
but because he took a jump
of 14 years he could bring
in black people, colored
people, white people,
bring it all in under a crisis with
a past that they could [inaudible]
And that's the only remarkable
effort that has come from about now.
Another thing is [inaudible]
>> I have so many questions.
I also want to say that [inaudible]
>> Antjie Krog: Yes.
>> And [inaudible]
>> Antjie Krog: I'm very sorry.
[laughter]
>> But I wanted to ask you about
-- not to get too personal --
but I wanted to ask you
about the idea of translation
as being perhaps a
negative political act
if it were rushing the
[inaudible] into English.
Are we losing their original intent?
Are we losing the indigenous
languages?
I'd love to hear your
thoughts on that.
It just seems as though
there's more being published
in these indigenous languages
and it's such an exciting thing.
Should those be translated
for our consumption?
>> Antjie Krog: -- My personal
obsession with translation is
when I close my eyes and
when I listen to the South --
what I call the South African sound.
This is all the literature,
all the poems, all of it.
Then there's this absence of work
done in the indigenous languages.
Afrikaans is there
and why are we there?
Because we are being translated.
And no one was interested in
translating Afrikaans during apatite
because you had [inaudible].
Since 1994 Afrikaans writers care.
The publishers are not interested
in having published every single
writer, pay someone to publish her
or him into English
and you become part.
That's how you end it and
now you are part of the sound
of the imagery, of the
stories, of the South African.
But all night I've been aware
that initially just poetry,
but the older I got about novels
that exist in these languages
that you can't buy
anymore because they're
out of print, no one reads them.
There's also another
problem that most
of these indigenous
novels have been written
in what is called classical post
novel, classical [inaudible].
And now the African can't read it.
There's also many of the
young black students that go
to modern city schools where
they learn no indigenous language
and can't read that.
But this -- so these translations
would bring those voices back
and maybe create real attention
that, "Okay, let's go there
and see how badly this
is translated."
You know? Or how truthfully
this is being translated.
So I -- for me translation
is the act of reconciliation.
It's a way of reaching each other --
because we have to
have advanced language,
write a book in which we
can imagine each other.
We can't now because
there's these absences.
And what I love actually most is
that there's a lot of suspicion
against these early black
intellectuals that they sold out,
that they were under the influence
of missionaries, that all kinds
of them you don't really
need to know what they say
because they are tainted.
You -- and when you read
these -- it's not so bad.
The quality of [inaudible]
is just unbelievable.
The kinds of descriptions and
things [inaudible] So I'm --
yeah, so it's an important
issue for me and I think maybe
that is the saving grace of English.
So many other worlds enter it.
And if a country decides not to buy
books translated from Chinese or --
I don't read books from the East.
Sometimes I feel [inaudible]
in my lifetime is more
than enough, you know?
I can't accommodate that, you know?
You -- yeah, and it's wrong, right?
It's wrong and it's -- you
need to take it all up -- in.
>> I read that [inaudible] is
kind of the way [inaudible].
Has any [inaudible] [laughter]
>> Antjie Krog: Yes, you know
sometimes I feel I could have died
at 18 because actually I
would have died [inaudible]
And it's difficult now
there's a scandal [inaudible]
Because we know what other kinds
of scandals [inaudible] did
survive [inaudible] volume
on the 18 female body.
And I was asking a [inaudible]
do you know of any photograph
of an old woman's body
that is not disgusting?
And he said to me, "No."
He can't get older
women to pose for him.
So I said, "Okay, I have a friend.
I will ask her."
And she lets him.
And so they go over where they
took an unbelievably beautiful --
and it's not a photo shopping.
It's all the moss, all
the [inaudible] old woman.
So that was on the cover of that
volume, [inaudible] Oh, my goodness.
The shops didn't want to
put it on the shelves.
Someone said to me, "How can
I give a volume with this
on the front cover for my father?"
Someone else said to me,
"[inaudible] I was too ashamed
to read it on the plane."
[laughter] You know?
Because it's also a
wise old woman's body.
So now you know.
I think maybe if it was a black old
woman's body people would feel it's
a political act [inaudible].
Now no one cares about
the old woman's body.
[laughter] So I can --
it also didn't sell well.
Although it's very [inaudible] Which
for me meant a lot that it created
such -- that people realize how
actually discriminating one is
to once the older body.
I may [inaudible] website,
sex between old people,
and that is truly disgusting.
[ Laughter ]
>> [inaudible] I noticed that
I happened to be [inaudible]
And I noticed that Lost
-- I noticed that lots
of books were [inaudible]
published in South African
and Afrikaans and English.
So it's not -- and then I don't
know whether original is Afrikaans
or in English, you know?
And so that is, to me,
Afrikaans is not dying.
It's still there.
And also, one thing
is that I [inaudible]
and accidentally I ordered
a book that is in Afrikaans.
So it was translated from
English to Afrikaans.
So that means that still a
lot of people read Afrikaans.
>> Antjie Krog: Yeah.
No, there's a lot of readers
[inaudible] buy the Afrikaans
speaking book.
Initially [inaudible] South Africa.
[inaudible] 94 was
politically [inaudible]
And in the end I voted back because
they say Afrikaan speakers come in
and are looking for their
books in their language,
but they most often they find
other books or order English books.
But they don't come to your
shop if you don't have a shelf.
So that was it.
The reason why Afrikaans
is under threat
at this stage is there
was one University left
who taught an Afrikaans [inaudible]
you know you could do anything
in Afrikaans.
And they decided to step away
from that, that they want
to be more South African University.
That they want -- yeah,
an English --
they want to appoint
lectures to someone
that speaks English and so on.
And that -- it means that
the third tier function
of that language is now completely
under threat because people go,
"Why would you go to a
high school in Afrikaans
if all universities are in English?"
[inaudible] I want to say
that it has become so strange,
this translation between -- that
some people have written books
in English and then the
publishing house will say,
"But this is actually
an Afrikaans story."
Later it's translated in
Afrikaans because they sell more.
So because Afrikaan
speakers buy that
and it's [inaudible]
English speakers.
So there are some [inaudible] one
famous that was written in English,
but it was such a free state
book that it was translated
into Afrikaans by the [inaudible].
>> I have [inaudible]
actually [inaudible]
that you did [inaudible] I think
it was on [inaudible] of desire.
Where you were making a
statement of [inaudible] Some kind
of [inaudible] story was
about crime, fear for whites,
[inaudible] stories that [inaudible]
promotionally very successful
[inaudible] So I was wondering
[inaudible] or if you see
that as a trend [inaudible] writing
in South Africa [inaudible] Afrikaan
community [inaudible] interested
in film and your [inaudible] what is
your relationship with [inaudible]?
>> Antjie Krog: There's a
[inaudible] before 1994 the writing
was [inaudible] I have
to say, it's --
since 1990 the decision with
people like Nelson Mandela
and his first cabinet, people
were [inaudible] were turning
to the bank, turning to their
[inaudible] to find black heritage
that means something for them.
And there's a [inaudible]
I think you put it, of --
a wave of literature about some
black man or some good person
in the past who has affected
-- he wasn't even being --
white children have been
brought up by black women.
And so there is a whole new
movement of trying to find her.
You already knew her
white name, where is she?
And so they found the children
of that person [inaudible]
find photographs.
There's a website where you
can post photographs of you
and your black [inaudible]
and ask whether anyone
knows anything about them.
So it's -- I think there's a
desire to redefine one's self
and redefine one's self as a
profoundly South African person
and not as a European subject.
Yeah. And the problem is with
things going so bad [inaudible]
so there are these texts that sell
out [inaudible] Africa
[inaudible] to be resurrected.
I have no [inaudible] although
Afrikaan [inaudible] There are
mostly all black [laughter]
[inaudible] This is an industry
that creates a lot of jobs.
It's [inaudible] that
is in Afrikaans.
And all of it must include --
if I want to look at it now,
if I want to find something
now it's on television.
Completely, you know bizarre
but [inaudible] And so on.
So you find that on TV.
[inaudible] You also
find individual art
and in music there's a lot
of cross fraternization.
>> Laverne Page: We
should wrap things up now.
Thank you so much for coming.
Thank you for coming.
It has been a very, I think
intriguing session here today.
Things I've never thought
about, never knew.
I just think that this was
very good for all of us.
Quite informative.
So thank you very much.
If you have questions
that you'd like to ask,
we invite you to come back
to our conference room
and you can ask questions.
We also have copies of "Lady Anne"
for sale in our conference room.
And we'd welcome your coming back.
So thank you very much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.